Satsuki kiryuin I will be voting for
Satsuki kiryuin I avoid talking politics
on this channel on this forum because
politics is divisive there's always two
sides canto and cons I there's Tokyo and
then there's Osaka I can have my own
opinion and there will always be an
opposing one that is the nature of a
healthy democracy but this is not that
this is about a megalomaniac who is
driven by nothing but ego a person who
cares exactly zero about the people of
this country a person who judges people
based on their clothes and wants to take
over the world with the help of life
fibers
but seriously guys is anyone else tired
of this presidential election that's
been going on for almost two years now
we live in Canada so we can't even vote
but we still keep hearing about Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump all the time
well forget about those two for a second
and think about this have you ever
wondered which anime character would
make a good president and certainly one
better than Hillary Clinton or Donald
Trump which anime character would you
vote for president would you vote for
Lelouch from code geass or maybe light
from death note or how about spike from
cowboy bebop this coming Tuesday on the
day of the American presidential
election we will be hosting our very
first live stream right here on YouTube
at seven o'clock eastern standard time
just as the election results are coming
in we're going to be live-streaming
presidential election 2016 anime
addition we invite all of you guys to
come and join us and tell us what you
think which anime character would you
want as president we're gonna have
special guests joining us on the live
stream including mackle not and simply
rose to awesome anime youtubers so come
and join us we will be taking your
questions hanging out and most
importantly while everyone else is
talking about Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump we're gonna be talking about anime
and guess who else is gonna be joining
us guys what up guys remember this guys
remember dis guy goes goes end is going
to be joining us for the live stream
they'll miss it feel free to get the
discussion started right here in the
comments and be sure to join us for the
live stream this coming Tuesday seven
o'clock eastern standard time together
we can get through this freaking endless
election I hope